NATO AT RUSSIA WOULD MEET T
UKRI HITRY  ALONG TIME. OME.
MERICA'SOSDIMILITARY LEADERSNOWR
MM
AS CIA DIRECTOR.
HE IS NOCHAIR., T
OU.
GREEIN
E S ITS RE
O  TO BREAK OUT? E INWAY  DESCR
I THINK IT WILL DEPEND ON THE P
MOST CRU
W COME OUT?STHREE MP W. BLE  HU
IN THIS MIDDLES
RATES GOING  YL.LATA MADE UTANTS
EQUIPMENT DEROPACT ON HIS HO FR
THE IMPA O B
OVTHHEATE OROFHE
IF TNG IN
ONI THINTHE HAT YOU THOSE
TT TARBUG TWCABLE TOE.
>> DIS A --
RUIAFTER PLAN A
FAILED, AN IS A PRETTY  S
IS OF ARTILLERY.
ESSENTIA D THESE ESD THEN THE R
AND CL
BATTLE RIGHT NOW? >> GBLOOCOIGHU
. EFENSES.LY, IF EARRENT S HEIRW
THEY DSSN TAKEFT HDEPOPUD BOTH A
SOTO TS
EY CLSEWHERE  UKRAINIS ISANTITY
OFFENSES FM HWEST S TY
LA COND
CHIDT.RUSHER C WEAPON SYSTEMS A
EY ARE LOSING.
SAMETHE LD JUSOR SOME
SI DONSTALL  IN E T MONTH IN TT
U TO PAND ON THIS IN
HAS SSIBIL
HA OR  RUSSIANS UR MON CANNS AC
AT THIBAOF FOR I PMONEY IANS.
OR
0,OF POTENTIALDIYOU
FRRE AUITED AR
U.S.O
ETERS.
PIECESY
S
YES, THERE S
L. WE
RONES AS
QUICKLY AS
T  THIS IN THERE. K THE POIB SO
THE RUSSIANS ARE I
ORMOUS QUANTITIES OFCRIEL.